we are expecting Bishop DB5 he's very
direct
yes he needs to be and there we go on
the board change yeah it's just so
difficult to admit defeat and to to
design knowing that you are just one
step away from your big dream of
qualifying for the candidates I mean
keeping the chances alive to qualify for
the candidates
it's a very sad moment for with it but a
fantastic moment for abasov it's very
tricky yeah when you play against Abba
so you feel like probably this is I'm a
favorite yeah this is a golden
opportunity and no he did make one more
move Bishop F7
grabs that Queen
we see checkmates on the board Peter
next move Bishop takes Queen
likely to be met by Queen to E8
checkmate
okay will he allow it on the board did
it right now just to show the fans I
don't think that he cares about defense
it's uh
it's just the Heartbreak yeah that okay
you don't want to depart but he takes
yeah we will get the chance to see the
mate
on the board the handshake and applesoft
is in the semi-finals
did it heartbreak for him eliminated
yeah complete terrible heartbreak at the
same time Euphoria for abasov the
incredible victory